[Musique]
g
simonet d'ânonner bonjour mon nom
costa bolton molto molto belle bon super
merci d'être sur le plateau de tv5 18
pour ce vip que l'on va vous consacrez
pour plusieurs raisons vous avez une
double actualité
bon déjà vous êtes yvelinois vous avez
habité versailles le chesnay xterra vous
avez travaillé longtemps à versailles on
va y revenir et vous avez donc une
double actualité à savoir ce livre
magnifique je porte et qui vient de
sortir mon italie chez aux éditions de
la martinière et vous avez aussi
instauré qu'il vous soit traitée dédiée
ou je ne sais pas où comme on dit un
potager dans le domaine de madame
elisabeth la soeur du roi louis saez à
versailles voilà plein de sujets abordés
ensemble on va commencer par le début
alors vous êtes donc italien où
êtes-vous né alors je suis née haas
alors salon c'est un petit village au
bord du lac lac de garde dans le nord à
laval nord de l'italie
c'est la région de la lombardie
en dépit bureau et les plus grands des
plus belles régions d'italie parce que
économiquement très puissante
on a des lacunes à des montagnes on a
des moments de la lampe ianu là on a
vraiment du tout d'avoir beaucoup des
produits on a beaucoup de produits
fermiers s'ajouteraient avait chaud
d'accord et je crois vous avez vécu dans
une famille justement qu'ils étaient
très attachés aux produits du terroir
votre enfance c'était ça en fait vous
avez connu tout de suite les joies de la
nature et des bons produits de la ferme
n'est ce pas là la chose importante ce
que j'étais j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
d'avoir éduquer mon palais depuis l'âge
de je pense que six mois six mois parce
que et c'est de là à part je pense que
c'est à partir de là que les palais dans
la loi commence à se développer
oman jour des beaux produits fermiers
ont pas en mangeant des produits
confessions et toujours des choses fait
baiser lalande d'alabama
les salariés du pape a vraiment du bon
produit pour moi le bios et s était
jusqu à l'ordre du jour d'accord et il
ya eu aussi des animaux est excellent et
ralaivola ferme les légumes
à quel âge vous avez tué votre premier
lapin je pense que j'étais mon propre à
la fin j'avais peut-être six ans voilà 6
mois à 6 ans sont des chiffres pour
votre part mais c'est des choses qui
donnent vraiment qui explique et
beaucoup de choses après pourquoi
pourquoi oui c'est comme ça mais
pourquoi vous êtes comme ça alors je
crois que très jeune a 14 ans déjà à
votre père a compris que votre voix
votre votre vocation c'était la cuisine
vous me dîtes si je me trompe
non non pas du tout c'était vraiment le
moment de choisir le type d'école les
études que je voulais entreprendre et
c'est lui qui m'a qui m'a quand même bal
donné l'idée en dix ans mais pourquoi tu
aimes les produits tient la cuisine tu
vois que tu fais des choses à maison
pourquoi tu veux pas faire pourquoi tu
veux pas dire cuisine est d'accord et
j'ai moi j'étais toujours de la manua
lité j'aime le travail manuel et j'aime
la fatigue corporelle je suis pas
forcément un grand grand étudiants parce
que c'est quelque chose qui m'a nui
moi j'ai besoin de ce contenu concret
d'aidé mais des foules et j'aime lactée
physique et 10 coups et du coup j'ai
commencé des études trois ans d'études
jeu toujours travaillé même les dates
des études parce que je faisais bébé
week end et les samedis les dimanches
d'un petit best-of des gardes et après
je continue ma carrière comme ça ok
alors votre carrière elle et malgré
votre jeune âge allait quand même bien
emplie déjà ses longues alors vous avez
rencontré après plusieurs postes dans
différents restaurants de par le monde
notamment à londres vous avez rencontré
gordon ramsay ça c'était une rencontre
importante pour vous il vous a embauché
bas c'était rencontre très important je
m'appelle encore les jo qui bat bauchet
j'étais encore jeune et j'avais besoin
c'est une servante qui a basculé à
échanger complètement ma vie ma carrière
et c'est vraiment grâce à lui qu'ils que
je lui je suis là ça fait passer dans
l'agglo niveau de la gastronomie peut
être ça m'a fait passer d'un haut niveau
de la gastronomie ça mais ça m'a permis
aussi des travées d'un milieu
complètement différent je suis passé
d'un petit vestiaire des avec 400
cuisines l'histoire avec 15 devant
cuisinier alors là on est déjà au
trianon palace à versailles a rejeté par
contre ce qui alors j'étais encore à
l'ordre donc comme on va vite et va y
aller là vous êtes très très va très
vite et après 8h devant que j'étais à
londres
on charge de ses hôtels au dallas et
oberthur il y avait cette opportunité
pour s'approcher plus pour réveiller
sous la cote est de l'ata rakes quelque
chose c'était vraiment beau souhaiter de
pouvoir revenir d'un pays latin et
c'était pas l'italie c'était la france
et des coups bas on l'a débarqué à
versailles en 2008 et vous avez été chef
donc pendant je crois 12 ans au chapeau
trio pendant 8 ans 8 ans pas d'accord
hélas depuis quelques temps vous avez
encore changer vous êtes vraiment dans
paris vous êtes au george lefort cézanne
hôtel oui voilà pour vous êtes à la tête
d'un restaurant méditerranée bout c'est
dur à dire méditerranéen italien disons
mots voilà après une étoile
on a les toiles les buts c'était des
membres de reprendre des bascules et un
peu ma carrière un bout de quarante ans
je me suis dit que je voulais revenir
faire quelque chose de vraiment je vais
mettre au débit en valeur mes origines
mais les originaux savoir-faire à
l'italienne et votre façon de travailler
aussi je crois exactement parce qu'en
fait dans ce livre que vous avez donc
sorti on apprend beaucoup de choses sur
vous et vous dites enlever les barrières
un peu plus de souplesse et un peu plus
de joie de liberté de créativité aussi
et puis vraiment votre adn italiens
encore par beaucoup de haut par beaucoup
de la dette italienne l'étal des
détaillants est vraiment très présents
dans le livre du web
et palaces parisiens très importants
comme les gens légende 2 sec je suis
lucide a rejeté beaucoup dit tagliani t
mais c'est le côté vraiment humble et
passionné dé voir les choses et d
accueillir les clients
les clientèles d'échangés avec la
clientèle chose qu'il avait peut-être un
peu du mal à faire d'accor oui vous avez
rajouté un peu d'humanité de chaleur du
soleil et du bonheur et du bonheur tout
tout ce qu'il faut pour être
voilà donc ce livre c'est un voyage en
italie dans votre italie on va on
parcourt grâce à ce livre différents
endroits d'italie ont fait un peu le
répertoire de tous les bons produits de
base indispensables pour cuisiner
italien ouais voilà papa je voulais pas
faire jusqu'en libre ce coup dur parce
que aujourd'hui on peut juste que faire
des photos messieurs et je voulais
vraiment raconter d'histoires c'est
raconter d'histoires c'est déjà la côte
est humaine
c'est ma famille à boire à votre famille
en bas de la masse et la reggina idji
d'assez elle pleure encore quand je lui
parle au téléphone parce que les trois
lettres chou elle est trop chouette
j'adore les dix ans et à 410 euros
janvier du coup il ya un grand défi il
ya en fait à faire des médailles a la
cote chez iba dia bâ fabi il ya des
patios il ya la passion pour la cuisine
et c'est une danse offre des produits
qui moi je pense que c'est le produit
indispensable des produits mettre en
valeur la cuisine aliens qu'est ce que
c'est que ccp né à la c'est ça va
de la cie c'est parce que moi aussi dans
ma brigade j'ai beaucoup des gens qui
viennent de partout de l'italie oui je
voulais pas juste mettre en valeur
l'italie du nord qu'est-ce-qui l'italie
du nord c'est très différent dans
l'italie du sud et c'était un mélange de
cultures qui deviennent alors des partis
en voiture dans les discours d'aubry on
est descendu au d'aller à faire la
chasse à la truffe ou d'aller avec à
trouver des des artisans qu'il faut
dupas maison les jambon de parme le
balsa abiquo jusqu'au botté h et bois ou
de les avoir des producteurs du fromage
d'alpage
alors juste
ce fromage rebelles là qu'est ce que
c'est juste or les cauris belle parce
que derrière produit il ya toujours
belles histoires et les clients aiment à
le connaître
7 fromages que ça fromage d'alpage qui
en cas de fromage qui ressemble beaucoup
à raconter way c2c probable que a changé
son appellation
parce que cette façon de faire régler à
l'appellation que c'est pour eux et ils
volent et puis il est rentré perdre un
peu les valeurs de cette appellation
alors voulu revenir obèses exactement
faire un fromage plus libres enfin les
fromages à la base il s'appelle est big
toe storico nom et baudoin il s'appelle
store du corry belle et si celui-là vous
l'utilisez dans votre cuisine et les
belles elles sont signées comme ça avec
donc des berti de myrtilles enseignants
parents et vous pour les ménages a chuté
au lait stocké à chez eux et après les
occuper à bout de deux trois quatre cinq
ans d'affinage
j'ai compris alors deuxième actualité
très importante aussi depuis depuis
combien de temps on vous a attribué
je crois que c'est une collaboration
avec josé mon départ se fait à trombe au
départ cela avait quelque chose d'aussi
loin que c'était là sa directeur de
l'hôtel a aujourd'hui à un nouveau
directeur si jane fonda deux
ventilateurs qui à jean claude qui vient
d'être élu à la tête du segment d'hôtels
je vais vivre avant de revenir un peu à
mes origines des courbes et dans le
reste on met des choses que je faisais
quand j'étais petit et je voulais
devenir plus locavore je voulais quand
même un sweat un circuit court mais qui
est pas basé jusque sous le sous l'effet
d'avoir potager parce que honda
reconnaît 3000 mètres carrés d'espacé
1500 mètres carrés cultivables dans
cette double qui est magnifique domaine
de madame elisabeth donc madame
elisabeth en plein coeur de gaza et
voilà avoir vidé de paris avec et
mickaël du valais que c'était un seul
responsable du bed du domaine monde
entre ces deux ans qu'on travaille
ensemble la première année c'était à des
tests pour pouvoir voir la fertilité du
frère qu'est ce que pouvait faire alors
les tests justement vous avez fait
pardon je vous coupe
vous avez vu faire des tests de terre
pour savoir ce qui allait bien cultiver
boston a cultivé déjà dans la première
année pour voir s'ils avaient quelque
chose qui n'est pas qu'ils marchaient et
on s'est rendu compte que la terre est
très fertile
les chaleurs sont rendu compte que je
pouvais produit vraiment beaucoup de
légumes alors on a fait quelque chose
qui est très compliqué à faire en france
où d'affaires un contrat entre autorités
publiques et le disait privée et nous au
loup on paie un loyer à aller ça soit 18
de là on voit pardon michael inquiète
donc le responsable du domaine tout à
fait et écouter et à côté c'est une
femme c'est une femme que ça va être les
habitants qui elle fait partie d'un
système de rente versée au social c'est
à dire qui on a des jeunes au delà des
anciens on a des eaux des gens qu'ils
ont besoin de réapprendre à betty keanu
embauches dont les aides ont laissé
deuxième vie ouvertement sur ça c'est un
autre volet de ce projet il ya le projet
donc locavore retour aux sources audio
etc
mais c'est aussi un projet social avec
l'avenir si cette équipe est il faut qu
ils étaient dans la deuxième année des
sportifs 5 à des honda pourrait battre
jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui on a produit
à peu près 4 et todd des légumes énorme
à blanc coeur de versailles et chose de
très important que j'étais à beaucoup à
coeur vous dire c'est que aujourd'hui
aussi aux anciens systèmes de recyclage
oui parce qu'il reste aux récup 60
personnes de notre déchets alimentaires
qu'elles sont travaillés par une start
up qui se dit dans les ag beast aller à
paris qui transforme sa au compostage ou
trois mois avec une nouvelle technologie
qui nous rachète les composent et on
avait dans mon potager
oui pour pouvoir pendant un cheveu de
vertueux et j'ai aussi que vous vous
déplacez vous avez un partenariat avec
poche hybride qui vous permet de vous
déplacer donc en poche électrique parce
que du coup il fallait vraiment cohérent
alors de vous emmener vos équipes
cueillir jeux d'arènes des équipes avec
odeurs full électrique avec une panamera
bien sûr que ceux de ce match auquel
elle doit être globale au niveau de
l'hôtel parce que j'avais aussi des
clients allaient qui aussi je prends des
clients d'hôtels et j'ai les abeilles au
potager avec vos sources pour prod et
légumes pour chercher des légumes et moi
et pour leur montrer qui aujourd'hui on
peut faire du luxe mais
on peut faire du luxe éco-responsable
très bien et vous avez je crois aussi
implanter des ruches
on a deux ruches on a six ruches
d'abeilles qui vont devenir 16 l'année
prochaine pour pouvoir prêter environ
500 kilos de miel et moi j'ai une
question qui m'intéresse plus
particulièrement les tests faut savoir
si on pouvait implanter une truffière
alors ça a donné quoi alors les tests
sont des temps d'analyser les terrains
ouais pour l'instant au dessous des
voeux sous deux coups mais toi positif
on doit détester de trois fois dans
l'année pour voir si les pouvoirs faut
savoir pour les truffes parce que dans
l'ue d'après les premières truffes de
noir à versailles la truffe elisabeth
ces nations
c'est génial un gros merci bravo tout ce
que vous faites et puis très vite à la
table du georges et j'encourage tout le
monde à allier ce magnifique livre qui
en apprend beaucoup sur vous déjà et sur
votre magnifique pays
merci à toi et à la prochaine à bientôt
de saab il ya six mois
[Musique]